I am going to show you what my day looked like today.
I wake up Nurse Lord Joe. Then we get the kids fed and ready for school,
which is in a little schoolhouse we have here on the farm.
We have a school teacher come in,
and it's a one room school room with the older kids,
and they love it. We love our teacher.
It works really well.
During school, I usually try to get a little workout in.
Then we get dressed, do our morning chores,
try to get some protein in.
Then today I decided to make some soup and film it.
So I set my tripod up and we just documented gathering food,
making food. And after the kids go to bed is when I typically edit.
And then after that, we packed everything up for kids practices.
So Daniel took the girls, I took the boys.
We got everyone loaded up and in the truck as soon as we made it there.
Of course, the girls were starving,
so we nursed, we Cheerios,
we drink milk.
Then we. We were reunited with the girls and Daniel
and enjoyed the most beautiful sunset I've seen in a long time.
And watch the kiddos play.